hello strange luke i'm really sorry i
couldn't be there i wish i could see all
of you meet all of you in person but i
was unable to make it i sure hope we can
hang out later on slack uh to talk more
about program synthesis and and formal
methods in general
so let me get started
second
there has been a lot of uh buzz recently
in academia and in industry in the last
uh decade or so about automating
programming generating code that is
correct by construction program
synthesis
uh neural programming ai
pair programmers and so on and so forth
right now while we may not all agree on
what these exactly mean or manage to
accomplish uh for this law uh talk let
me just refer to all of these buzzwords
and efforts as program synthesis okay
and and we came we can debate their
meaning later on slack so program
synthesis is actually not a recent
keyword at all and uh it goes back at
least to the 1950s uh to a problem uh
posed by none other than church
about circuit synthesis and also uh we
attribute it to this uh paper from the
1970s by mana and voltinger which is
quite dramatically titled as
synthesis as being uh the dream as
something that takes a dream and
converts it into a program
so let's pin down the definition right
so what exactly do i mean by program
synthesis in this talk well uh it's the
problem of automatically generating a
program that conforms to a user's intent
or or a dream uh and there are three
main parts to this
problem if you see which are
interrelated
how should one specify the user intent
how should uh one design or implement
the synthesizer given a certain user
intent and uh
again given a certain user intent and a
synthesizer how should one ensure that
the programs that are generated indeed
confirm uh to the user's intent or even
better can one actually design a
synthesizer that can generate programs
that are correct by construction right
so uh what church and uh mana and
waldinger uh proposed was that the user
provide complete formal specifications
of the program's expected behavior okay
given which the synthesizer uh could
then systematically deduce a program
that is guaranteed to be correct by
construction which is great uh but let's
look at what these specifications could
look like
uh so here on the right i have a program
that is actually computing the max of
three uh integer valued variables so if
one wanted to specify
this uh using a complete formal
specification uh all we would need to do
is to provide uh this lovely
specification right and and this is
fairly easy for a lot of folks but i
think we can debate about whether it is
easy in general right and in fact it's
not at all uh clear if it's for the
average programmer if this is easier
than to come up uh than to write the
program itself
so uh
what we would truly like is to perhaps
tell the synthesizer as little as
possible and have the synthesizer
somehow read our mind in fact if we
wanted to democratize programming and
make it more accessible this is what we
would need right we don't want people to
have to write these complete logical
specifications
so inductive program synthesis seeks to
address this particular specification
problem in classical program synthesis
and more ambitiously democratized
programming by only asking users to
provide a hint of the programmers
expected behavior okay so uh for
instance we might ask the user to just
uh state the problem in uh what she
wants in plain old english right hey can
you write me a program to compute a
maximum of three integers or maybe uh
uh the user can give the synthesizer
some more information such as the name
of the function its type signature and
so on and this and you know that copilot
uh can handle uh information like this
right
or perhaps uh we uh try to take a step
towards uh specifying more correct
behavior and we give a few examples of
the expected input output behavior of
the program right now all these uh
specifications that i showed you are
instances of partial or incomplete uh
specifications okay and hopefully we can
all agree that these tasks are certainly
easier than writing the program itself
and also can be done uh quite easily by
non-expert users who may or may not be
able to are willing to write uh formal
specifications right
all right so uh let me also state that
not only uh does the specification
problem get easier with inductive
synthesis but if you consider the
synthesis task itself remember that's
the second part to the synthesis problem
if you consider the design of the
synthesizer itself it becomes
significantly more practical more
automatable more scalable when the
problem is to find a program that is
simply consistent with the set of
examples as opposed to finding a program
that is consistent with the logical
specification over the entire input
domain okay so
in fact if one poses the synthesis
problem carefully then the design of the
synthesizer can reduce to the design of
a smart search algorithm remember then
remember that the classical program
synthesis used deduction based uh uh
program synthesizers and today uh it's
it's more practical to view this as a
search problem okay so how does this uh
exactly set up
some suppose we allow the synthesizer to
additionally accept a syntactic uh
template of the space of possible
programs the program space
in the form of a grammar or some domain
specific language
or
an incomplete program with whole some
kind of partial program or skeleton or
more recently in the form of some
classes of publicly available code in
github and other repositories right
so if we have this program space then
the task of the synthesizer can be
defined as essentially to find a program
in this program space that is consistent
with the partial specification okay this
is a search problem
so i just said that uh this setup of
inductive program synthesis and partial
specifications makes the specification
problem easier makes the design of the
synthesizer easier but what about
correctness okay
so this is indeed a challenge and it's
easier to see why this is a challenge if
one
notes that inductive program synthesis
can be viewed as an instance in general
of inductive learning right where the
goal is to learn a general function or
rule from a specific input output pairs
now inductive learning is great but it
is uh
it has lots it suffers from many many
complications right such as ambiguity
overfitting brittleness which makes it
very hard to reason about the
correctness of the inferences and
classifications uh obtained in in
such learning engines
so let's see um
how these uh
what these mean in the context of
inductive program synthesis and to
illustrate this better let me just focus
on the case where our partial
specifications are input output examples
and so they capture at least some notion
of of correctness right
so ambiguity in the context of inductive
program synthesis means that there can
be a large number of programs that are
consistent with a set of examples okay
uh
that might be fine but unfortunately uh
not all of these programs are going to
exhibit the implicit intended behavior
on unseen inputs right hence that some
of these programs are going to overfit
to the examples and they may not
generalize to unseen inputs
so uh let's not go through uh why this
program is wrong but i can uh look tell
you that later on slack
but the problem with overfitting is that
because some programs may uh satisfy the
implicit specifications and others may
not the synthesizer could very well uh
output a program that is consistent with
the examples but overfits and does not
generalize right
now there's another issue called uh
which i refer to as brittleness right so
to illustrate what this is uh in the
context of inductive program synthesis
let's take the scenario and focus on
this last input output example which i
have highlighted okay now if if we just
swap these last two inputs right so you
see that this is essentially the same uh
list if you will of elements except uh
the last two inputs are swapped
then we have an instance of a
synthesizer uh switching from an
incorrect program to the correct one
okay essentially to a program that is
semantically quite different uh from the
program it generated earlier and this is
a
case that that i found out while playing
around with the synthesizer okay so this
does happen
so uh
now that we know all these problems how
do we deal with correctness okay have we
lost out already on the dream of program
synthesis
well not really i mean because uh
inductive program synthesis inherits all
these problems from inhere from
inductive learning the sensible path
forward is to also learn from and adapt
its solutions right uh so how does one
address these issues in inductive
learning
well uh inductive bias of course right
which is essentially a set of
assumptions made by a learning algorithm
in order to perform induction which is
essentially generalization from a finite
set of observations into a general
function over the domain and the common
one for instance is ocam's razor which
assumes that the simplest hypothesis
that is consistent with the observations
is the best right and guides the
learning algorithm accordingly
so in inductive program synthesis
there has been already a lot of work and
most existing work attempts to guide the
search for the desired program
uh by
applying inductive biases on the program
space such as ocam's razor which in this
context corresponds to the smallest
program
or by designing highly structured dsls
or domain specific ranking functions or
more recently uh by using neural guided
heuristics right and all of which can be
done with or without interaction with
the user
now uh it turns out if you look at them
carefully all of these right including
the ranking functions the search
heuristics
are almost always based on syntactic
features of programs
so while these syntactic notions of
inductive bias have certainly made
inductive programs and this is more
effective and have enabled us to get
more ambitious about realizing the dream
of program synthesis the ambiguity
overfitting and brittleness problems are
far from solved okay so now the question
is what's the next step towards
realizing the team the dream how do we
better do better generalization in
inductive program synthesis
so here's my answer in brief
let's look towards semantics okay
and i'm not the first one to realize
this there have already been some
efforts in applying various notions of
semantic biases to the search space in
the form of types for instance or some
uh
some kinds of um abstract program
semantics or some uh semantics of uh dsl
operators or components again with or
without a user and i think all of these
are steps in the right direction okay
but there is still a lot more to be done
in terms of exploring uh opportunities
uh theories and techniques for
semantically biasing search spaces
uh because semantic biases are still
definitely not among the first things
that come to mind when designing or
developing an inductive synthesis engine
so this uh finally brings me to the
focus of our work and really the topic
of this talk uh our mantis project on
semantics guided inductive synthesis
okay
so many of the ideas here have been in
the works uh for several years some of
our initial ideas were in the space of
inductive program repair uh in this cab
2016 paper on clothes and in this pldr
19 paper on sem cluster
and i'm not going to dive too deep uh
into these but let me just tell you
about them briefly right so inductive
program repair can essentially be viewed
as a synthesis problem
and requires thinking about the distance
between two programs okay so you want to
modify the incorrect program in a way
such that you do not generate a program
that is too different from the original
program right so this requires a notion
of program distance and in these two
papers we defined and showed the
effectiveness of using certain notions
of program distance that are based on
semantic features of programs typical
productions of program distance are
based on syntactic features okay how
much did you change the program syntax
uh for instance so we said no we need to
think about cement how how much
does a modification modification change
the semantics of a program and propose
various notions of program distance
but that's all i'm going to tell you
right now let's uh
talk more about this on slack if you are
interested what i want to spend most of
the remaining time on is our work on
semantics guided program synthesis okay
so let me start with the ideas in our
recent pop-up paper on on sketch ex
now uh let's go back to this problem of
ambiguity right where there can be many
programs that are consistent with a set
of examples but not all of these
programs exhibit the implicit intended
behavior on unseen inputs right and
hence may overfit ah to the examples and
fail to generalize on uh to unseen
inputs
now suppose in this
maximum example right
we have this this the illustrative
example i'm showing all along is that is
the same one it computes the maximum of
three integer value variables
now suppose in this example uh an oracle
magically tells us uh informs us about a
certain property of the program okay in
particular suppose the article tells us
that the program is permutation
invariant so the program output does not
change
when the elements of the program input
are permuted
with this additional knowledge it turns
out that for this example
it's the synthesizer is able to
eliminate the incorrect program and
steer its search to the correct program
okay so permutation instance is a
relational property and this is clearly
an instance of applying a semantic bias
to the search space
all right so perhaps you are thinking
now
how should one apply this bias how does
one apply the bias uh how does one bias
the program space towards finding
programs that satisfy permutation
ingredients
so we could of course ask an oracle or
the user
to write up a logical formula that
encodes permutation ingredients and ask
the synthesizer to enforce it right but
this would defeat all the tractability
arguments i made earlier uh for
inductive synthesis okay so we
need to try to apply this bias
efficiently using some partial
specification of permutation in variance
so that we stay respect the spirit of
inductive synthesis right
so here's a simple uh clever idea okay
why not apply this property to the given
examples by simply permuting the inputs
and uh keeping the output unchanged
thereby generating additional examples
okay now this has the intended effect of
placing a semantic bias on the search
space okay so this is great can we now
uh apply uh
this uh can we apply other properties uh
semantic biases corresponding to other
properties in a similar way because this
seems like a very simple way to bias a
program space
now the answer is yes in fact for a
large class of relational properties
that essentially relates the change in
the program our input to the change in
the program output we can use this very
same technique of applying the uh
semantic bias okay and uh
i'll refer you to the paper to our
proper paper for a fairly general
formulation for all these properties but
let me just mention a few other uh
properties that
are subsumed uh by this class of
properties so we've already talked about
permutation ingredients there's
permutation preservation uh so the
permutation in the output is the same as
the permutation in the input or value in
variance if you apply uh an affine
transformation to the input the output
remains unchanged or value preservation
which says that the
output has the same a fine
transformation as the as the input and
so on and so forth okay
so for all of these uh relational
properties we can essentially apply the
same clever strategy for uh which takes
a set of user provided examples and
applies the property to obtain a larger
set of examples that include the
perturbed examples right
so this is our key strategy it's very
simple for biasing the search augment
examples with properties and then use an
existing inductive synthesizer you're
not even redesigning the synthesizer to
generate a program from these augmented
examples okay
and yes i hope you have noticed that
this is similar to the idea of data
augmentation in machine learning right
where for instance for learning an image
classifier that can generalize better to
unseen images one generates a larger
training data set by applying various
transformations or perturbations to the
original data set of images right
so uh ours is definitely similar but our
domain and perturbations are different
for instance we don't limit ourselves
only to label preserving transformations
right we also support perturbations
where the labels or the outputs can
change with respect to the input changes
so all of this means that this strategy
is uh is quite general it can
technically be applied to all kinds of
inductive synthesizers uh to make them
more generalizable right in fact it can
also be applied to ai based uh engines
such as copilot something to think about
so another question on your minds
hopefully now is
where do these properties come from who
provides the properties right and let me
show you three different ui's with uh
varying degrees of user involvement to
answer this question
so the first ui uh that i have here on
the left is a property selection where
uh this is the one that places the most
demand on the user okay so the user
selects a set of applicable properties
from a set uh finite set of properties
right
the second uh ui the second user
interface is the property validation ui
where for each property the user is
asked to validate or invalidate some
perturbed examples some examples
obtained by applying the property to the
original
examples right and if the user validates
these spot up examples then this green
outer synthesis engine assumes that this
property holds
okay and the user button here is as you
can see is obviously uh less than in the
first ui but the user actually has to
know the property versus just validate
or invalidate some examples
and finally in this third ui this is the
property inference ui this i think is
the coolest ui where we only expect the
user to just provide input output
examples okay uh and uh we are able to
fully automatically infer the set of
applicable properties so this is this
looks like just this looks just like the
standard setting uh for uh example based
inductive program synthesis that we have
been seeing
so let's now see uh how the
outer green synthesizer needs to be
designed for each of these examples i
mean the reason you there is an outer
box and an inner box is because
the design of the outer box
uh always uses uh an existing uh
inductive synthesizer as a black box and
builds on top of it okay so the the gray
uh in our box is you can assume that to
be an existing inductive synthesizer
that's just used as a black box
all right so uh let's look at the
property selection ui uh
here the design of the synthesizer is
the simplest because the user does a lot
of work okay so for each user provided
property our
engine essentially implements our key
strategy it applies the property to
perturb the user provided examples and
then simply uses the existing
synthesizer to synthesize a program uh
from the resulting augmented set of
examples okay uh so let's just introduce
a perturbation engine that takes care of
of all this of this p strategy
in the property validation ui uh if the
user validates the examples for
according to a certain property our
engine assumes that this property holds
and proceeds as before with our
perturbation engine and
an existing uh inductive synthesizer
used as a black box
all right
now in the third and the coolest uh ui
uh that i mentioned before our engine
seeks to infer properties that are
consistent with the synthesis problem at
hand okay
and uh while it's added uh what we try
to do is actually in for a maximal set
of properties that is consistent with
the
synthesis problem at hand
now uh
again i'm not going to dive too deep
into this for but for those of you who
are familiar with uh smp solver
satisfiability modulo theory solvers
and the partial backs smt formulation
then let me just tell you that we pose
this inference problem as a partial bax
smt problem and use that to infer a
maximal set of properties okay but we
know that this is not the only way to do
this there can be many other ways to do
the property inference so let me just uh
pop in a generic property inference
engine here in our pipeline that models
our synthesizer design all right
so uh
let me uh show you how all of this works
in a certain scenario that we evaluated
in our bubble paper
so we specialized our framework to an
existing general purpose program
synthesizer called sketch i have added a
reference to the original paper uh here
and
we call our synthesis sketch ax sketch
with augmented examples okay
so our data set primarily consists of
benchmarks that are drawn from various
repositories associated with the sketch
synthesizer
and uh from a certain track of an annual
uh synthesis competition that is
actually held in
our conferences okay there is this
annual competition called syntax guided
synthesis competition zygus
um which has been helping the
development of uh better and faster uh
synthesis engines okay so and a lot of
our benchmarks are taken from a certain
track of this uh competition the
variable domains that we use are
essentially uh scalars uh arrays and
matrices over booleans and
and
integers
program space is defined in terms of
partial programs with holes okay which
are called sketches that is the input to
the sketch programming language so the
user has to provide a program
which is i mean the sketches input
language is essentially a c like
imperative programming language
and uh which is equipped with an
additional construct for a whole okay
and so a user provides a sketch of a
program uh with false and that defines
the space of programs that the
synthesizer searches over
so this is our evaluation setup
and uh
let me first show you uh the success
rate of the different synthesis engine
engines for um benchmarks that do
satisfy some properties okay now uh what
is the success rate over here it is
essentially uh computed over 10 runs for
each benchmark with each run using a
different randomly generated set of
three examples
uh this gray one first one is uh is
baseline sketch and our three different
uis uh follow this in pink blue and
green which is the second third and
fourth bar okay
so the first thing i want you to notice
is that the success rate of the
validation and inference uis
uh matches that of the selection ui okay
so our property property inference works
very well
uh that's that's the first thing and the
second thing that we're excited about is
the actual degree of improvement so all
of these instantiations of sketch eggs
provide a 60 improvement in the success
rate of baseline sketch so if you can
see the substitute of baseline sketch
for these benchmarks is only about 50
percent and we are able to raise it to
uh 80
with our notion of property guided
synthesis
and if we focus on a certain type of
benchmarks the bit vector benchmarks
which actually sketch was originally
designed for then this improvement
becomes even more dramatic uh because
the success rate of baseline sketch was
only 30 percent and we were able to
improve this uh to about one ni
by one ninety percent okay so we are
very excited about uh these results uh
but um
this is not it there's a lot to be done
and let me just before telling you about
what we are planning to do in the future
let me just give you a quick preview of
our ongoing uh work in a domain that i
believe many of you will be interested
in just functional programs okay hence
the name cis lambda
so
sketch happens to be a synthesizer that
is not tuned to be an inductive
synthesizer okay most inductive
synthesizers have a lot of
heuristics uh like i mentioned syntactic
biases that help steer them towards the
correct program okay so one might wonder
is our uh is the amazing improvement
that we saw uh over sketch primarily
because it's not even designed to do
inductive synthesis okay
so we have we are trying our other
domains as well and uh
in this domain of functional programs
now we use another uh state of the art
black box inductive synthesizer called
lambda square which is at least partly
type driven okay it given exam input
output examples it can synthesize uh
functional programs uh
and the synthesis algorithm is uh
is par partly time driven okay
so even in this domain as this uh
example illustrates our old problems
show up okay so if lambda square is
given this input output example it fails
to recognize that it is trying to
compute uh um the user wants to compute
a program that computes the maximum and
and obtains a program that is highly
overfitted to this example right and we
have already uh found that our clever
tactic works in this space as well okay
so we can again uh tell the synthesizer
that this is supposed to be permutation
ingredient generate more examples
apply the
semantic bias to the program space and
steer the synthesizer towards the
current program there are lots of other
interesting ideas that we are exploring
in this domain including redesigning the
program synthesizer to be semantics
driven
but uh this is very much ongoing work
and uh and i and that is all i'll be
able to talk about right now okay but
ask me more about it on slack
so as i move towards uh wrapping up let
me just uh mention some cool problems
that i think we can all
think about in this in this space okay
there are many opportunities obviously
to advance similar ideas in many other
synthesis domains i just mentioned uh
functional programs but in general uh
you can do it for
string manipulation data wrangling sql
queries all the other domains in which
inductive program synthesis is already
applied these days okay
so one could i mean so and the strategy
is is is what i've already told you
right you first identify your
interesting relational properties figure
out how to infer or learn certain
properties
with or without a user in the loop
and then use a perturbation engine with
an existing domain specific synthesizer
treated as a black box like we did right
so
just using the same design
there is there is a lot of room to
explore the applicability of this idea
in other domains
but what if we change our design a bit
what if we open up our existing
synthesizers or uh design our own
synthesizers to incorporate relational
properties within their search
algorithms itself right like we are
doing in our syslanda project
so this opens up the possibility to do
much more right we don't we are not
restricted to examples anymore because
uh application of these uh relational
properties required us to start from
examples and generate more examples
we don't have to be restricted to
examples anymore we can
look at broader classes of partial
specifications and we do not need to be
restricted to the particular kinds of
relational properties we looked at in
this talk right like
uh permutation ingredients we might be
able to consider arbitrary relational
properties and perhaps other semantic
properties too that neon may not be
relational
so ah this is great and eventually it
would be interesting to uh
essentially
improve how we learn about these
properties okay so another way to think
about this whole synthesis setup is its
property guided synthesis so it would be
great if we could actually learn
probabilistic models of the property or
semantic signature of a certain domain
and use that to guide the search right
uh so
that is essentially the vision i have
for uh this body of war
and let me wrap up uh with just a couple
of slides uh these are the amazing
students and collaborators who have been
and continue to be an essential part of
this project
these are all my students past and
present on the top
these are collaborators from academia
industry
and uh
here's my last slide uh the the takeaway
that i want you to take i want you to
remember from this talk many of us are
taking our own small and big steps
towards realizing the dream of program
synthesis especially uh in the context
of partial specifications okay
so as we do this let's just remember to
try and see how we can make use of
semantic properties
to help realize the dream
thank you
hi uh thanks for your talk um
i
the the examples you gave had um
the
kind of specifications provided
in
uh text you know in um
structured kind of json-like
um data formats do you know if there's
research being done
um where
to appeal even to non-programs to people
who don't think in terms of lists and
integers um i i'm thinking about you
know the excel spreadsheet being the
most used programming language in the
world um
people
uh specifying
the computation that they want to happen
um through graphical means um like a
spreadsheet or um you know shapes colors
that kind of thing
okay i'm glad you mentioned spreadsheets
because uh microsoft excel since 2013 i
believe
has been shipped with an inbuilt program
synthesizer okay and so this was one of
this is one of the biggest success
stories of program synthesis so uh there
is a program synthesizer that can
actually generalize from
uh users uh input output uh
data and generalize that uh
to essentially infer the
intent of the user and generalize it to
multiple roles okay
so there is work on this there is work
on uh
taking natural language specifications
and trying to interpret them uh more
precisely there is work on uh trying to
use other uh other graphical methods of
uh using specifications and trying to
make them more precise so yes people are
looking at multiple modes of
specifications thank you
hi um
so what the like your example you use
the the dream of the max function uh so
what's sort of the current
state-of-the-art
uh like complexity of dreams that
have a realistic chance of
you know generating
reasonable interest rates so
so it depends on which uh i i mentioned
three parts of the program synthesis
green right so it mention it depends on
which of these or how many of these are
important to you for instance co-pilots
can do a lot right but it cannot uh
ensure uh correctness of any kind it
cannot even ensure that the programs uh
generated can compile
so it can handle programs of of uh i
mean it can scale well it can take uh
that are very natural looking but
it doesn't do well on the correctness
part
on the other hand many of us in academia
who are focused more on correctness
i think the main challenge that we are
facing is actually uh scalability of the
synthesis engine so the kinds of
programs that we are able to synthesize
are still small right uh but they are
correct so uh
i can't quantify where we are right now
uh
but the
the goal is to find the right uh
trade-off or sweet spot between
scalability and
correctness
while ensuring that the specifications
are easy to obtain
thank you
thanks for your talk um i was wondering
about um if there's any current research
on
uh
synthesizing specifications like formal
specifications which then you could
derive
programs from synthesizing them and then
they're automatically correct
great question uh
yes there is work on specification
inference
from uh
existing programs that are
more or less believed to be
trusted to be correct trusted code bases
uh or or big code or repositories there
is work on specification inference as
well
and there on the other hand uh so this
is this is pro this is these are
specifications that are exist extracted
from existing code bases
and on the other hand uh complementary
to this approach there is work as i
mentioned earlier on interpreting uh
user documentation comments and so on
and trying to extract some properties
from there some specification from there
as well
okay i think we are at time and we're
going to um close the session error
thank you so much for to rupture
thank you
[Music]
you